[Music]
at the time of its launch in 1996 al
jazeera was seen by many as merely a
drop in a media ocean dominated by
mostly western news channels and outlets
25 years later that drop has caused
ripples the world over forcing a tsunami
of change across the globe
before al jazeera's launch the arab
world enjoyed little if any media
freedom
citizens from iraq to mauritania were
told what to think and say through
state-owned channels that focused on
glorifying their leaders whilst ignoring
the concerns of ordinary people
but when the channel began broadcasting
under the slogans of the opinion and the
other opinion and the voice of the
voiceless it earned the respect and
recognition of millions and its
viewership rocketed
while most media outlets were embedded
with american and british forces during
the occupation of iraq al jazeera
reported the otherwise untold story of
the human cost of the war
as it had done before in afghanistan but
this came at a heavy price
al jazeera journalists were injured
arrested and even killed among them
tarak ayub murdered by a u.s airstrike
on the capital baghdad in illegally
occupied palestine al jazeera has always
been present its cameras broadcasting
the daily struggles of palestinians
living under israeli occupation
correcting a narrative that had
previously failed to tell that side of
the story killed by the israeli army
from the second intifada to the attack
on an eight flotilla headed to the
besieged gaza strip and until the recent
war in 2021 the network has reported the
story from all sides and angles
again this resulted in its offices in
gaza being bombed this time by the
israeli army live on tv
in early 2011 the network's motto of
being a voice of the voiceless
crystallized as arab capital of the arab
capital erupted with anger and millions
of people took to the streets demanding
freedom justice and a better life these
are the people al jazeera was on the
ground reporting live while local
regional and even some international
channels failed to acknowledge the
historic protest that became known as
the arab spring
all the while the network remained loyal
to its other motto giving airtime to
everyone including the regimes that were
cracking down on their own people
in 2017 and a testament to how
influential al jazeera had become a
blockade on qatar was imposed by egypt
saudi arabia bahrain and the united arab
emirates they insisted the channel must
be shut down for the blockade to be
lifted a demand rejected by qatar's
leader whose country hosts the network
so you're not going to shut down no
we're not going to shut down which is
here the country's ruler sticking to the
commitments made by his father on the
day the channel was launched back in
1996
rest assured the channel's freedom will
not be restricted politically it'll be a
platform for every opinion
what started off as an arabic language
channel 25 years ago is now a global
media network that includes five
different channels several websites and
a plethora of digital platforms
all have cemented themselves as leaders
in their field
all of them seeking the human story and
striving to speak truth to power
a quarter of a century has passed and
what was once described by former
egyptian dictator hosni mubarak as a
tiny matchbox is now a global media
empire whose flame continues to burn as
a beacon of free press in a region that
has never needed it more
jamal al jazeera